hey everybody and welcome to an insane
wild ride with stevo this week we've got
shaggy two dope of the insane clown
posse and i'm telling you it is wild man
plus you know like these guys talk about
murder a lot and their music
and i'm telling you that you need to
murder your thirst
with liquid death baby right here man
this is what it is all about it's this
groovy company that
makes
water in cans that look like beer and
this is the sparkling water right dude
it's time to ditch the soda man
and drink much healthier
sparkling water from the alps that's
right dude
and you know what's so great about this
company is that they're they're swearing
death to plastic because these cans are
not made out of plastic they're
infinitely recyclable aluminum so yeah
liquid death is saving the world and
making you way healthier too plus dude
are they generous you go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo
and you get free shipping on all of your
orders of water and merch dude it's
crazy free shipping plus i just had
someone tell me man like
they said thank you for hooking me up
with that for all the great deals that
the wild ride podcast hooks the
listeners up with and yeah man
support this company because they're
good people doing good things and
they're good for you
liquiddeth.com
stevo for free shipping on all your
orders of merch and water yeah dude now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen shaggy 2 dope
yeah dude sorry you've met the gorgeous
paw briskey very gorgeous thank you just
a mustache is the best touch yeah thank
you nothing creepy
right and we would normally have scott
randolph but the [ __ ] popped for kovid
what does that mean the [ __ ] pop for
kovad what does that mean tested
positive is that what that's the saying
now the [ __ ] pop for closing i don't
know steve has invented it i think did
you just make that up isn't it great
makeup man i made up such a [ __ ] dope
catchphrase and i forgot what it was it
could have been used on a sick comment
everything i'm telling you and i forgot
i blew it i forgot it i mean yeah you
got to write that down i know that when
athletes test positive for steroids it's
called popping for steroids i don't
watch sports yeah okay well i don't know
professional wrestling but nobody gives
a [ __ ] if they test right
right they're probably supposed to try
to get in deep
razor blade yeah dude man [ __ ] thank
you for doing this it's the first one on
uh my own actual bus i bought this what
the [ __ ] oh you own this i don't know i
mean and to be clear it's not like a a
fancy expensive tour bus it's an rv
which i you know
let me tell you something about this man
this is fancier than any [ __ ] tour
bus i've been i'm not i've never been
like when stefanie's busting no [ __ ] or
princess no [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying nobody like
that because i don't know what level i'm
at we just drive on whole ass [ __ ]
buses but this is [ __ ] this is like
being in a mansion right here man i
don't take this over a [ __ ] tour bus
i'd be on any day what dude and it comes
with a fancy driver all that stuff yeah
well yeah we had to hire the fancy
driver but yeah dude [ __ ] killer um
and it's interesting that you say that
because
um
you
say i don't know what level i'm at but
your level is pretty epic dude you know
i think that your level is pretty epic
and what i love
is that uh it's evident you're not a
flashy guy you're not like you know
but dude you've got to be like just so
wildly successful there's only like you
and violent jay right like in the actual
group i mean we're this whole team of us
you know but like publicly it's just us
too i mean dude it's interesting man
like it was 2004
was it it was 2 000
yeah 2004
and
and um
i uh had
new year's eve it was paris hilton
birthday prayer for my new year's eve
party i'm partying with kid rock
i've told this story i feel sorry for
you
i'm sorry
right i mean
but it was a funny story we did a lot of
cocaine oh i bet you did yeah and uh and
i remembered saying to kid rock that i
just heard on the radio that for that
year
of 2004 that metallica was like the
biggest grossing i was like i can't
believe the amount of money metallica
made on tour and kid rock looks at me
and says yeah but those [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] split it four ways
he goes you know you wanna like you know
each of those people didn't
touch me i mean like but when you're at
that level does it really matter if
you're splitting it four ways crazy
right and to call somebody a stupid
[ __ ] on top of it that's the only
thing
what the [ __ ]
they do to him well there's a lot of
coke involved like right so who knows it
could have been something right
unnecessary
but but yeah you guys you know
presumably splitting it two ways and so
that that you know
yeah i mean if that was you know the
truth of the matter
if that's how it was cut down and we
were smart about our business actions
and it was cut two ways i'd probably be
sitting real pretty yeah okay all right
well you're saying there's like agents
there's people who are managing a lot of
bad decisions
no no i'm saying you know saying that
like like i mean great decisions sure
bad money management or just just i mean
like the gathering for example the
gathering of juggalos yeah we're not
going to stop going at it
last year's the first year we've ever
like turned a profit on it wow wow ever
you know what i'm saying we're usually
[ __ ] hundreds of thousands of dollars
in the hole every year you don't see
anything so we're so used to losing
money it was nice to turn around and
make some you know and that plea that
didn't get split two ways
yeah but yeah hey don't worry about my
finances
i'm not trying to make you uncomfortable
not trying to make it i mean dude how
cool is that though that the gathering
is still growing like and your guys
whole fan base is still it's like you
haven't even peaked it's fantastic
like i feel like a lot like and this is
no [ __ ] especially like dog
everything is so like uh everything's so
like new the horizons are so new now
it's not just touring and putting out
records nowadays it's all this uh
streaming and you don't see streaming
shows or streaming every [ __ ] thing
you do you know it's just so it just
busts everything wide open you know and
uh you know yes it was a hotel like you
better get the [ __ ] out of somewhere but
uh just ignore that or what ah
we probably don't want to just ignore
that
my fancy turns the driver did park it
right in the middle where nobody can
even get around to run in and check in
and then
it's like
oh that's
that was the most that was the most
angry postmates knock i've ever heard i
thought you knocked like a cop
yeah you said that there's uh there's so
much more than just touring and putting
out albums yeah it's just it's just
everything's open nowadays how many
people saw your your mom's house podcast
here that was epic i don't know look at
the numbers you haven't been hearing
about it not numbers guys yeah no doubt
you know what i'm saying and you know
that's that's a podcast you know what
i'm saying and uh i think podcasts are
great because anybody can do them now
you don't have to have a network you
don't have to you know none of that [ __ ]
man not only can anybody do whatever the
[ __ ] you want you know right not only
can anybody do them but everybody is
doing that right
it's only a matter of time it's too many
it's too many
kids that are like kids you don't say
literally that are like
single aged teenagers and 20s that are
getting too many millions for the man to
be like allowing this to happen for too
much longer right you know ryan's
getting too much [ __ ] money over
there ryan's world [ __ ] yeah
you know it's that's enough for that i
think somebody's gotta swim and be like
hey man now i'm gonna need some of that
that youtube money you're getting you
know right they're about to start
clamping onto that [ __ ] watch for sure
man it's just crazy that so many people
can have huge audiences it's awesome
though it's a new age of [ __ ] man i'm
telling you yeah hey congrats on that
movie dude yeah i i watched it what
movie oh yeah
i think a movie yeah what are you
talking about maybe it came out yet it's
already blowing up i i mean we'll see
what i will
see what happens
you got you had a dog commander right
back we'll see what happens like come on
fire right now
like if anybody's comfortable going to
the movie theater this is the question
the movies are [ __ ] packed in
michigan i know that i've been there all
the time okay yeah they're [ __ ]
stupid packed you guys are [ __ ] as big
as hell on the bodies yeah it's about to
be fired man all right dave what thanks
for telling you [ __ ] yeah
front and center yeah i love it man and
my [ __ ] leopard skin thongs
and i'm gonna get like dude i'm gonna
get the fake stevia tattoo on my back
dude epic um so you your your movie i i
couldn't see anything documentary yeah
the documentary
but it was in theaters yeah yeah it was
in select theaters and uh i'm not sure
where they're taking it you know what
i'm saying um
we we really didn't personally well we
we
you know we were aware it was going on
we did a lot of interviews for them and
right you know so we were we're with
them the whole way but we didn't
ultimately it wasn't our documentary i
understand but they came through and did
an awesome job with it you know what i'm
saying in uh anyway what's it called uh
is it what's it's uh united states oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah united states of uh
insanity united states of insanity it's
called united states of insanity versus
[ __ ] maybe i should really know it right
yeah you probably should we're learning
but uh but i think that the way you just
described is is fantastic because had
you guys had too much control over it
yeah you know that that wouldn't be a
true right documentary today
it was very objective it wasn't that the
the point wasn't to kiss your ass and
that made it good yeah and this is that
this that whole situation wasn't seen
you know what i'm saying right it's like
then i'm just kind of well i know it's
not behind for everybody right you know
there's still people that feel the i see
keep looking outside yeah i'm good man
i don't care all right cool sorry man i
don't mean to put you no no
what's the status with the whole fbi
gang [ __ ]
ah yeah
the insane clown posses fans the
juggalos being labeled as a gang by the
fbi it's a tough situation one might say
a hard situation and that's exactly the
situation your wiener will be in when
you take blue chew tablets that's right
they're delicious chewable tablets with
the same active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis and it costs only a
fraction of the price i use them all the
time man lux night we have so much fun
with it i'll come home and she's got a
blue chew uh
sitting out on on a plate you know and
she'll say she made me dinner and i'll
feast that blue chew and then we go to
town
man it's just a lot of fun and if you're
thinking about whether it would be a lot
of fun i'm telling you it's a lot of fun
plus you don't have to
like go into a annoying or uncomfortable
awkward in-person doctor visit no dude
you go to bluechew.com
and you consult with one of their
medical providers right there and it
couldn't be easier couldn't be quicker
and then you know what you got your
bluetooth tablets on the way plus if you
use the promo code stevo at
bluetooth.com boom you get an entire
month's supply of bluetooth tablets
completely for free all you gotta pay is
five bucks for shipping dude you can't
beat it man
you just can't beat it so go to
bluechew.com use the promo code stevo
for an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets for free
all you gotta pay is five bucks for
shipping your boner's gonna thank me and
so will you now let's talk about the fbi
i don't know the the last
they threw all of our [ __ ] out of court
last i know you know what i'm saying in
the
the when you say threw it all out of
court anything we could throw on them
they're like get [ __ ] out of here right
right right yeah they're stupid you know
what i'm saying it's fbi you're not
gonna [ __ ] win basically you know
what i'm saying and um so uh the
their resolvation was oh i don't know
what the word is resolution resolution
whatever i said it was basically they
just don't put out the list no more
okay they didn't say that list don't
exist no more you know what i'm saying
but they just you know they just don't
do it no more so i don't know if they if
it was if that's
you know saying so
who knows where it's at they won't tell
us it was a [ __ ] up situation that
that it if they're like oh well it
wasn't really an official list it was
just more of a a loose guidance
and it's like okay well great your loose
guidance [ __ ] me and my people in jail
a lot of people got [ __ ] up over there
you know it's crazy right but uh yeah i
mean
we did what we could you know what i'm
saying and yeah i don't know anything
else that we could have did you know we
did i guess the american thing you could
do you know right and i'm not a i'm not
an old political guy or
avenues to take with that [ __ ] is there
any
like angle on it where it's like being
classified by the fbi as a gang
like it gave you street cred it was like
kind of like cool personally bragging
rights
um said there was no wall with a family
would be [ __ ] wrong with that street
cred [ __ ] right so there was you're
telling me there was there was no silver
lining whatsoever been like up in the
bullpen since you know so so i don't
know right i'm saying something yeah but
is it what's up once i spend a little
time in the pen i'll let you know how i
was going with the whole game thing you
know but
i try to stay away from it i mean i i
know that that uh like being a howard
stern fan yeah no doubt you know like
like that the fbi
the gang [ __ ] like
definitely got definitely got howard
stern talking about you guys so much i
mean
while it did limit you guys it got you
out of hot topic with your merch and
definitely put a lot of limitations
they want to touch we can't do
gatherings
west of like [ __ ] indiana
right right because the further you get
out west the hotter the gang [ __ ] is you
know saying nobody wants to [ __ ] because
now your insurance you know now you've
got a [ __ ] gang rally not a festival
you know ensuring a gathering of the
jugglers is already crazy you know
what's that so doing doing trying to
assure a gang
convention or whatever right
impossible you know and then you gotta
clear it by city councils right they
don't want that [ __ ] in their cities man
it uh and it's it's it's it's nice it's
insane man there's a lot a lot of a lot
of craziness behind it a lot of people
don't see so dude the gathering that i
was at was the first one that was
profitable that's great man because of
you dog
you straight up man you showed up and
[ __ ] everybody got paid look at that
dude how about uh chris hansen you had
chris hanson there boy somehow oh yeah
friends with chris he texted me
merry christmas that's a cool line with
chris man i'm gonna [ __ ] run all my
[ __ ] like daughter's boyfriends
through him you know what i'm saying be
like yo i have a seat with chris hanson
right quick [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
like why don't you sit down for a second
yeah oh my god when he says interrogate
him dude that's fantastic what did he do
at the gathering to he was close to the
stage yeah goes to the stage [ __ ]
awesome
it's pretty awesome man
but he didn't show his butthole
i showed everybody my butthole and it
was the most [ __ ] man the most
notable butthole that's ever been shown
on your stage maybe i
i've ran through the whole gamut of
emotions with your butthole man
straight up man your photo is like
[ __ ] mesmerize me amaze me
that's [ __ ]
it's like sat in the bathroom punching
the wall thinking about it
yo dude let me put it this way i don't
know who took that [ __ ] picture
but
he needs a pulitzer prize for that
[ __ ] folder for that [ __ ] photo
if anybody's in the dark right here
there there's there's there's
there's a big thing with the the
juggalos when you go to the gathering
the jugglers you go to an icp show you
see jugglers anywhere it is very
important to them
that to see buttholes that's what they
think they scream for they love it they
don't show their butthole right they're
like everybody dude show me your because
what's up with the butthole thing i
can't answer that i don't know i don't
know how they're passionate about it
i've never showed my butthole they
really want to see everybody want to see
they really like they're not prejudiced
against the butthole they don't know who
the butthole's on right if it's dirty
clean right they don't give a [ __ ] just
like i mean
after after the gathering of the
juggalos i started i had a [ __ ]
butthole beauty pageant at uh at at one
of my shows what a good idea yeah you
had
i showed everybody
you know i showed everybody but but uh
but it's interesting so so i'm hosting
the gathering juggalos and i'm like they
want to see my butthole who am i to not
to withhold this thing that they want so
i showed them my butthole
and because of the lighting maybe like i
spread it as wide as i could that was
probably a factor because people were
talking about this on the way here yeah
like we were like was he like trying to
[ __ ] or something i was just like i
don't know
no i think i think that people aren't
used to seeing buttholes with the cheeks
spread that
lighting i think the lighting was just
so perfect dude i pulled them apart as
until it hurt i pulled my butt cheeks
apart
so you text me this photo the day after
the gathering and i'm like i text it to
my girl and she goes dude what the [ __ ]
man you could fit the entire head of the
microphone in that gaping [ __ ] you
know like why are you having a game i
couldn't believe what i was seeing i
couldn't believe it either i was like
wow
and then you
you came back okay i just heard the
crowd go ape [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying right and then he comes back and
he goes yo man i couldn't spread my my
ass as hard as i could
you know what i'm saying
in the next video
yeah and then yo i get a picture it's
sent to my phone okay i don't know who
took it or whatever it was the most
crazy yo they said yeah it's it takes it
to me the next day you guys are
this relief
that that i know if anybody googles
stevo's butthole then thank god i've got
uh a
like popular brand of hot sauce called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole so
like you're gonna go you're gonna get
thousands of pages of just [ __ ] about my
hot sauce you need to use that for the
label
pulled open and chew next to it
very comparable man right and very
because it's probably it's normally like
a rhetorical request
you know it's close to being concerned
you know what i'm saying like like if i
wasn't sitting here and laughing with my
body i might be concerned like yo you
might want to get that [ __ ] you might
hurt somebody
yeah taking a mandingo or something yeah
you might want to see a doctor about
that that's uh starting so i i started
this uh this email list as well as this
uh like uncensored page i i didn't put
it on my uncensored page yet i'm waiting
to kind of tell the story of my butthole
but but but on my email list
i'll tell him with you i'll i'll take
care i'd love to have a journey with you
i would love that i would love to feel
like i'm a part of it a little bit you
are and and we can keep we can use this
this footage to help tell the story hey
man what we have to talk about camera
and here goes steve stevo's butthole for
your viewing pleasure
i mean dude dude
let's let's back in are we gonna see it
right now
hey man i like shaggy a lot i feel very
comfortable with him and that's why i
went to go show him that you know plus
maybe i wanted his opinion maybe he
thinks it's unhealthy maybe it is
unhealthy but you know what is
absolutely healthy which you need to try
it's this killer new product called just
egg
it's totally plant-based totally
cholesterol free it's got actually a
cholesterol lowering
polyunsaturated
ingredient it's
totally good for the planet man it's
delicious too this is like
so much better than anything going man
and i love all this plant-based stuff
but i'm telling you just egg is the tops
man it makes the best quiche the best
egg sandwich the fluffiest omelets and
scrambled eggs you know what you need to
go to the
darn grocery store and find just egg
because not only will you be treating
yourself to the most delicious breakfast
ever but you're going to be saving the
world too and think about the chickens
man the poor chickens they
all this industrial chicken farming and
all the egg business you know
it's no bueno it's not cool so what is
cool
just egg you gotta try it man it's the
new you
is what it's all about man the new you
eating healthy doing good saving the
world and having a great time doing it
so get out there and try just egg and
thank you just egg for sponsoring this
wild ride yeah dude now let's see what
happens here
you can't do i can't look directly at
your bottle it's like look at that sun
dog i can't please don't show me your
butt
i just wanted to prove to you that that
it's not my god
what were you going to prove you could
do it again
i was going to try and like establish
make sure you ain't got no ulcers
i was going to try to prove that that
it's not actually gaping that it was
just the lightning
right but dude i sent a mass email
and it's crazy like this email list is
in mass just so you know yeah dude like
like it's crazy with that with it and by
the way every single email comes
absolutely from me
and and i have analytics to see how many
people opened it and five thousand
people oh i sent it to my mass emailed
it
i was like guys my butthole is uh is
something of legend and and and
more
yeah
legend of the lord i think of war
ah
your partner violent jade like there was
uh he announced that he had like uh what
was it a heart problem yeah uh
yeah i mean you know i don't i don't
know i know what it is you know what i'm
saying but i you know i don't like to go
around getting it to get with it because
i don't know
appointments with him but yeah he's got
he's got some [ __ ] going on from our
stance like a favor or some [ __ ] like
that which is
as long as you you know saying you
maintain your [ __ ] you're good you know
what i'm saying right right okay that
has pumped the brakes on our touring you
know what i'm saying yeah you know come
on man we're about to be 50 in this
[ __ ] i did jesse you're about to be in
a touring band when you're 50. come on
man you know what i'm saying i'm about
to be 50. i mean i'm i'm a couple years
out yeah but you're you're like you're
[ __ ]
in a mansion
all right with your four homies just
[ __ ] having fun you know what i'm
saying i mean it's pretty much bring it
back to you know what i'm saying i mean
we're both in a situation where we're
we're pushing 50 years old and we're
we're still climbing yeah you know where
we have
i just feel like it's the beginning like
with all this new [ __ ] on the horizon i
feel like you were saying it feels like
the beginning you know what i'm saying
it's like some whole new [ __ ] it's crazy
that like and it seems like like it's
giving a breath of air to everybody you
know what i'm saying that's like from
like like you know from back like you
know it's giving all of us like first
breaths to air now we get out there you
ain't gotta wait for [ __ ] to come out on
in magazines or nothing anymore you know
second you wanna say [ __ ] that's
dangerous for some people though right
man you know what i'm saying you might
be in a bad mood and say some stupid
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying but like
for the most part it's just like you can
watch it happen in real time now you
ain't got it like right you know
for the next episode or next magazine or
for mtv
and all that it's so cool now man yeah
and then you can control it too
when i came up
we had to get like our show ordered we
had to get like
green lit we had to get producing right
yeah yeah approvals and and and uh shop
it pop man it's a pain in the ass right
and so yeah and in that respect it's
killer now how many albums do you guys
have now is it like 16 or i i honestly i
don't know you come saying yeah and you
just you just came out with a new one we
just did yeah like
our main we got like a maze series you
know what i'm saying which is
six og boys you know what i'm saying
about one of them two of the records are
well one of them is two so really seven
you know what i'm saying okay
and then uh after this record we got one
more what's the name of the the newest
one it's uh yum yum bedlam
all platforms all that [ __ ] right now um
just dropped on halloween
um
and uh but yeah um other than that holy
[ __ ] man we got yeah we gotta we got
tons of records man here how do you feel
about this streaming stuff like the
spotify and all that like uh honestly i
i i don't even know how to keep track of
that [ __ ] with the numbers and [ __ ] now
you know what i'm saying like as far as
like how you get chart and all it's just
so [ __ ] well right and and the
revenue like uh of course it was when
when physical cds were the way like like
and then you you were
you've been doing all of it man see like
that that's that's what like
me and like uh my crew and my company
you know saying that's what we knew the
most yeah i'm saying was
selling records you know for sure i'm
selling references
to our old school style you know what
i'm saying you sell records and you get
on the [ __ ] road you know what i'm
saying right that's what that's what was
ingrained that's what we did you know
that's what we
didn't tell recent you know what i'm
saying for sure and uh you know once
once uh records
are obsolete you know say it took us a
minute to get our foothold
with the you know what i'm saying as far
as like the whole just streaming music
when i started you know let alone
[ __ ] straight and everything else you
know what i'm saying but but it's all
pretty much good now you know we stepped
into the new [ __ ] century over here a
new millennium whatever yeah yeah so but
but i'm loving it all now you know did
you always put out records on your own
label no we've been on a lot of labels
man but the cool part is we've never
we've never been kicked off a label
we've never been dropped none of that
[ __ ] we've always found a loophole right
or something to get out of our [ __ ]
deal we uh
we uh well we started our own label from
the psychopathic records and that's
we've always that's always been our
imprint no matter what we've been doing
besides but uh then we started out with
jive records and then uh then uh
hollywood records which was owned by
disney they bought us out
of jive and then uh island bought us out
from hollywood so it was always a number
on the merged with def jam and they
didn't renew our [ __ ] because of the
shuffle they just overlooked us so we
were able to get out of that contract
and we signed with this independent
called d3
and then they went under
so then now now we we're just back to
just doing it which is great now because
now's the time to be independent you
know
you know yeah so it's just like you know
what i'm saying it's like the sharks
we're just like above them [ __ ]
and i you know saying and after all
these years it's like we
we figured it out that the reason why
especially
like you know the heads back in the day
of mtv all that [ __ ] they all [ __ ]
couldn't stay like they swore they'd
never play us again
they [ __ ] hated our guts you know
what i'm saying
but well i mean we told the [ __ ] off and
all that and back then to the powerhouse
you can't do that you know what i'm
saying right right right but uh it's
it's like full circle man you know what
i'm saying it's just like you don't need
that [ __ ] no more you don't need all
that mtv and [ __ ] you know
and all that just made us more hungry
you know what i'm saying so
right out there and grinding all that
you know i was going to make a whole
point on it but i forgot where the [ __ ]
i was going with it yeah we were talking
about record labels it was kind of
boring
everybody's got the crybaby record label
shits but yeah you know and basically
it's like
we we we started not knowing [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying so we we didn't
have a financial back no [ __ ] like that
a lot of the products you know saying
they got like a rich guy that helps them
out or whatever we're just a bunch of
[ __ ] idiots off the street well you
know why and we still are you don't say
the craziest part i i would i would say
that you guys are super not idiots
we're smart idiots right because uh when
we spoke with violent chin we don't need
to go through it all over again but but
paul brought up about how he was
in college and his college professor
included
oh i went to a music business program i
can't hear man yeah no worries
i was in a music business program yeah
in orlando and they talk about you guys
and they're like icp is like you know i
don't know they've just cultivated like
an independent audience they're doing
their own thing it was like you guys
were used as sort of a
business model the right way to do
things how you guys uh but you picked a
city
like where was the pistol yeah and i
spotted jay about this you threw like a
dart and yeah it's real [ __ ] man i mean
there were a couple more that didn't
ride as hard but like that didn't stop
us you know what i'm saying like we
threw i think one of them hit like
madison wisconsin but the main one hit
the dallas that we were able to pop in
yeah was dallas you know what i'm saying
so that's real [ __ ] we did throw a dart
and it because
because uh that's when we're on jive
records in in uh we i mean we were
selling
tens of thousands of records on our own
just in detroit like right on flint you
know this detroit area you know what i'm
saying right i mean you're like you
don't want to be unheard of you know
what i'm saying and
we you know i'm saying and it was us kid
rock and esham you know what i'm saying
we're the three local boys that were
like the big dogs you know what i'm
saying and the whole time we thought we
weren't [ __ ] we're like yo these guys
are [ __ ] us up what can we do you
know they're getting all these label
attention this net not even knowing the
whole time that them bullshitting us was
fuming us to we were smoking the whole
time we didn't even know it you know
what i'm saying so all that like
[ __ ] has made us work even harder
you know so and
so we're selling tens of thousands i
mean like like 90 000 records just shy
just in detroit you know what i'm saying
and you're like we got to do this
elsewhere so you throw it down so we
signed with jive records you know what
i'm saying and um
and
they did we just took a [ __ ] a record
came out wasn't doing nothing you know
what i'm saying but jive wasn't doing
anything and you know we're salty as
[ __ ] just like anybody but now looking
back at it yo how the [ __ ] they didn't
know how to [ __ ] market us nobody no
label has ever known how to market us
that's the problem you know what i'm
saying they nobody could do it that's
why we've always had to do it you know
because nobody else knows how to you
know say it just comes natural to us
because
we don't know anything else
so you throw the dart it lands on the
man
was the main one that's when we attacked
first and just being there for a couple
weeks just like hitting high school with
samplers hitting the nightclubs flyers
and samplers just like being everywhere
vans being street teams street teaming
to levels that [ __ ] [ __ ]
learn lessons from you know right
and um and it started popping off in
dallas you know what i'm saying so we're
like yo okay for sure we know this is
job [ __ ] around them they're not
doing their end right they're definitely
not pushing nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
about you yeah we would go to the stores
in dallas be like yo you know we're on
job records you'd be like yo we don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
it's not on our catalogs nothing you
know what i'm saying so we'll be like yo
you know check it out oh you know
whatever the [ __ ] you had to do you know
we started doing that with other cities
and [ __ ] you know saying
yeah we made a pop ourselves and that
was just like the whole thing and that's
why we were so quick when we got a
little bit bigger told mtv on the sucker
dicks you know what i'm saying because i
love it because it's like they you know
it's like you gotta walk on eggshells
with these [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying it's just like you know
you'll [ __ ] them you know but
that stifled us for so many [ __ ]
years but it turned out to be a good
thing because all those [ __ ]
are gone now
you know what i'm saying and we're still
here so now it's like with people that
don't these [ __ ] old [ __ ] from back
in the day there's nobody's just sitting
there hating on us at the level they're
used to before it feels kind of
you good you know
getting a lot of love lately yeah and i
think that's because of of just all the
all the people that were in charge back
in the day are old and retiring now that
they had this [ __ ] just back in the
day hatred for us you know
[ __ ] off and stuck our dicks rebellious
kid [ __ ] you know
i actually believe
that that might be
how the fbi gang
[ __ ]
did help you because once that came out
it got you so much
so much attention so much media exposure
and and this the whole story of it is
like man can you believe it like this is
[ __ ] like these guys aren't a clown
and so now like you you got people
thinking that the the fbi did you wrong
and so now they're kind of rooting for
you and i think that maybe turned the
tide for you a little bit you know
you you are right uh right about that
because like i mean
people that that that hate the [ __ ] out
of us before i mean even i mean because
you know i didn't just hate him they
[ __ ]
i wouldn't be like wrestling like hating
oh i love to hate these guys no
[ __ ] are like yo [ __ ] them you
know
but even those people
you know saying when this [ __ ] came up
it would they're just like yo what the
[ __ ] is this this is insane these guys
aren't that [ __ ] bad you know maybe
you gotta [ __ ] them but not [ __ ] them
like that sure right i'm saying that's
just accidents uncalled for that [ __ ]
you know okay now here's another thing
is the the nobody can call you a gang
member or an even remotely violent
person after they see
your attempt at assaulting fred durst
how do you know how you kind of drop
king look man i don't know i don't even
know how to fight like a professional
wrestler exactly everything is the work
exactly i mean
like
a little while ago sitting right here i
thought of that i remember like oh my
god the [ __ ] of the the fred durst
attack
you know what i i you know because i
know he probably will see this on this
format and i would like to say not just
the fred durst but everybody else on
that stage including uh uh uh was it dj
lethal is it i don't
know no it's not mugs is this dj i don't
know when was that uh i don't know
[ __ ] some years ago okay
but but uh but yeah i want to apologize
to everybody that was on that stage
because that was some whole [ __ ] man it
really was i wasn't up there to harm
nobody i really wasn't trying to drop
kick him because come man well you you
clearly weren't trying too hard well
yeah it was like wrestling style but i
want like wrestling fred durst didn't
take the hit like oh you got to learn
somebody runs up on your stage when
you're up there that's right that's some
whole [ __ ] you know that's yours
that's your personal area for that hour
however long you're up there right and
coming inside of that is whole [ __ ] and
i violated that one
and i would like to personally apologize
to every man not just on that stage but
that was involved with that show and
that festival
[ __ ] respect man no [ __ ] it
really was respect
what surprised me about that
was that you weren't wearing your makeup
thank you that was after we had
performed earlier you know what i'm
saying i think you would think it was in
flip-flops and basketball shorts
right like straight up like it was came
out of a [ __ ] meth house or something
the idea that you would step on stage
without your makeup was more surprising
to me than than how badly you performed
there wasn't a professional setting
where i was right right right right
right
right and whatever yeah i mean i i was
doing it it was it was fun to laugh
about it
i'm sure i'm sure nobody has any hard
feelings about that
oh really yeah at first like from first
but rightfully so you know what i'm
saying but right heels and if there is
any saltiness i apologize we see them
i'm sure when you see me you can you can
[ __ ] give me a [ __ ]
[ __ ] wrist burn there you go maybe
make it all good i mean dude i think
it's i think it's classic with your guys
with your makeup do you enjoy the fact
that without your makeup you're probably
fairly anonymous yeah fairly anonymous
and you get to still kind of walk that
way yeah you know yeah all right there's
people know but yeah i imagined a lot
more anonymous than you especially
riding in this [ __ ]
yeah
i just remember back in the day wrapping
our buses like right you know what i'm
saying like with the records and just
being like you small pulling these small
towns and [ __ ] it's just being right
insane just everybody would come out
from every corner of the town we get a
lot of honking while we're driving oh
yeah
i haven't seen any cities but i'm not
like watching the window
you'll see it right um and what
[ __ ] huh tonight is the third show with
the bus and
so far man it's a good experience
i'm not i'm not i'm not regretting the
right where have you been so far uh it
was kalamazoo michigan then last night
was detroit last night was cleveland and
then
do a little little tonight okay yeah so
you just sleep when you guys are rolling
naturally right yeah i mean we leave in
the morning and and uh that's the way to
go uh did did i hear you say that you've
bought tickets to the show tonight no
you're everybody doing man
it's a support
we are going to have to head that way
pretty soon but i i got a question yes
and i hope this isn't getting through
dude it would be [ __ ] unprofessional
to not uh
ask about the actual icp murders
the icp murder right there's there's
been a bunch of them right people
identifying as juggalos who that's not
icp murders how does that hurt right
i know like he's like don't put that on
me that's like
when i was out here
when i was on your podcast yeah i um i i
i explained this and i'm not trying to
make you uncomfortable or
i'm laughing you could make me
uncomfortable okay good good but but uh
when um we were talking to violent jay
on the podcast and i was like oh man
dude i want to join the gang how do i do
that he says oh you just get a tattoo so
i'm like [ __ ] right on dude i'm gonna
go guys i was like i love tattoos i love
gangs i [ __ ] love clowns like come on
let's go right you know
so i got my juggler tattoo oh i've seen
it so great and and and i wanted to make
a big deal out of it so i got like my
crew together and like we camped out we
planned it out we filmed this film yeah
yeah it was awesome we filmed the whole
thing but but before i got the the ted
the night before i got the tattoo i was
like oh i wonder what this means and i
like googled you know like
juggalo tattoo and like the [ __ ] the
google feed it's just like
man
[ __ ] with the hat [ __ ] [ __ ]
attacks and you know like and then i
read an article with like one juggalo
carves a hatchet man tattoo off of his
roommate because he didn't really
deserved it and i was like thinking all
of a sudden i was like well wait a
second is getting this tattoo gonna
actually put me in [ __ ] danger like
am i live with a crazy person
i don't you can't speak on craig crazy
people will be crazy no matter what the
[ __ ] they're exactly you know what i'm
saying angry jack the ripper probably
used to listen to [ __ ] mozart did
mozart catch a rap
you know what i'm saying it's like
jackass fans ended up in the hospital
like right is that is that in the name
of stevo yeah is that your problem nah
you telling them to be doing this [ __ ]
at home
you know what i'm saying yeah what i
always said was uh it's not my fault or
sorry it's not tony hawk's fault every
time a kid falls off a skateboard no
it's not you know what i'm saying hey
it's not icp's every time someone carves
someone's skin off you know right right
okay kids so we approached that topic
and yeah person you're a crazy person
i felt my journalistic integrity sound
well done
i was like is that even steve over there
no no that was stephen that was steven
yes what was your question so i got a
question like
you know i was here with steven again
i used to be in a ska band and we
wore these checkered pants and at first
we were like all stoked on the checkered
pants and then it didn't take long for
us to be like and [ __ ] these [ __ ]
like do we have to wear the pants you
know so scott of course exactly
but it became like this chore that we
had to do right you know and so i can't
help but be curious like yeah
everybody's lazy man pudding
are you still in that band did you guys
make it no no i wonder why yeah there
you go
people
go on to do things it's the dedication
man you don't say you don't stop other
the people that stop are the ones that
don't make it yeah
you know what i'm saying the people that
don't stop are the ones that are
successful you know it's not easy as pie
yeah
how people that diet are the ones that
lose weight you know sarah do something
about it you know right muscular
[ __ ] lift you know what i'm
saying yeah exactly okay you can do it
in under five minutes put on your makeup
oh no no i can't but i look like [ __ ]
okay i'd say to make it look look good
give me about 10 minutes or so okay yeah
cool otherwise i'll just like [ __ ]
like like perpetrate like throw on like
a fake beard or something act like i'm
being silly for today you know what i
didn't bring up is is is uh the whole
[ __ ] beef you weren't there when uh
when i was a a [ __ ] i wasn't there no
i was not there i don't even know what
state that one document it was hearing
all about it
came back like don't [ __ ] him i'm just
like of course i was a writer i was like
yeah [ __ ] him yeah yeah yeah yeah for
sure you don't say it
well thank god i didn't have to worry
too much about shaggy
but um
yeah that was that was a crazy thing man
and it was really healing for me to uh
to that's cool and i understand though
cause i you know what i'm saying i've
been to rehabs up and down that so i'm
still like to this day you know what i'm
saying still in the mix i mean it never
stops you know right it never stops for
sure but yeah like um you know i i saw
that video the the violent j you know
you guys put out he was talking about
the beef and i was just like damn man
[ __ ] like i wish i would have thought to
reach out before seeing that you know to
make things cool but dude i feel like
now
like
it's just dope man like uh you know i
feel like
very healed from from that i'm i'm happy
too because like seriously that that's
something that will come up every now
and then too you know what i'm saying
like i'd hear about it now and then not
like crazy right right but every now and
then y'all remember that [ __ ] you don't
say if you're like yeah i remember that
[ __ ] yeah i don't like [ __ ] nuts but
i think like it would always be like i
bet you ain't even [ __ ] like that no
more it's some [ __ ] you know so but yeah
yeah it's always good to [ __ ] to
clear away the wreckage
you know that's some
some back in the day [ __ ] of course
nobody gives a [ __ ] about it no more but
still though yeah that's good just you
know and now we're at now we're homies
exactly i'm talking about it man i i if
if we get any more down we're probably
like [ __ ] bad for each other dog
right the [ __ ] that we probably get into
you know right i mean just [ __ ] break
some bones i can't be around too much
you already caught my face on for yeah
dude i didn't tell you i thought a fun
makeup thing like there was a point
before i got sober i was on the the
roast of gene simmons i ended up getting
kicked out of like like because i i like
peed on danny bennett bunny dude
did you make it out there no i didn't
even i didn't even
they dragged me out before the [ __ ]
thing even actually started you peed on
danny bonaduce yeah
had all these great jokes [ __ ] to
tell on the roast and then i never got
to tell them but one of them
well let's hear them thanks man one of
them was uh i said
man i thought it was funny when
kiss
took off their makeup and went on tour
without makeup
but god damn it was [ __ ] hilarious
when they had to put it back on
you know like like uh
insinuating that that like someone had
said like guys like you look like [ __ ]
younger audience perhaps you need to put
the [ __ ] right right
yeah there you go that was cool but you
know we come out like but i just felt
that that joke didn't land with you guys
maybe peeing on tiny bonaduce was a good
call
you didn't have to do that on a national
stage
like i don't say like what
you saw what you just like he was just
chilling you just had your penis out and
peed on him i mean when it was i was
drunk well yeah of course you gotta
start with right right
and uh you weren't what have you peed on
him i think i was peeing into a bottle
and kind of using him as a shield to try
to hide it before you guys were sitting
there there in some picture i'm just
sitting there you just walk danny
barducci was in his legit roast chair no
is this
this was just uh recovering dana
[ __ ]
[ __ ] fit for vodka again
baby it's a good thing
trust me
i'm just chugging
[Music]
thank you yeah dude [ __ ] man um yeah
i pissed out a bottle like like kind of
hiding behind him and there was just an
epic photo that this comedian great
comedian craig gass took and uh craig
gass
had a photo yeah he's like he's like
dude look at that i've got a photo of
stevo and it looks like i'm peeing on
danny von gucci
i was pissing into a bottle kind of like
tucked behind him and that was enough to
get me
it was it was enough to get me kicked
out yeah
it was enough to make a big sense
that's a lot that's like a lot of
celebrities there and [ __ ] huh
yeah um
there there was it it was pretty wild
man
was that before
you better have to keep your penis what
was the roast where tyson punched you
are you running oh yeah yeah
i missed all kinds of [ __ ] ideas you
got punched in the face
you had mike tyson hold his hand out
while steve ran into it i broke his nose
i dove that dove into mike tyson's fist
he just held it out
i did all the work yeah yeah yeah and i
broke my nose on it well yeah i imagine
did we record it we're gonna put that
video were you trying to tell them was
this this is back in the day or this is
more recent that was that that was more
i was at least sober then that was in
2011. okay yeah
ah good times okay so they invited you
back to the roast after even after you
peed on danny pontoon they weren't like
banned from roasts i wasn't banned from
roasts but the gene simmons roast was on
a e ah
they don't do those roasts that much
right they're not doing roasts
i mean it's a pretty special like you
know reserved for like pretty huge
people
yeah dude do you have any more questions
i feel like i hate kind of short but uh
i feel like we got to get ready to go do
the show in the show yeah yeah why would
you tell me what like what
what are you promoting and when's true
going back on yeah i don't know yet
we're talking about like leaving next
fall but nothing's in concrete yet you
know what i'm saying so i just i'll just
feed into the camera whatever so uh i'll
just talk to you how's that let me dude
either way you want to do it i wanna i
like your eyes better than that i i
wanna i want you to let us know what's
going on with you and uh what we can
expect and and where we want to send
people to help you out yeah for sure so
so right now uh yum yum bedlam is out
you know what i'm saying this is that's
uh the fifth album of the second uh
joker's car deck you know what i'm
saying okay so that's out right now you
want to get that or uh or [ __ ] off how's
it doing uh is it honestly i i don't
even i'm not i'm not musical
music isn't it you know how like the
charts no more
audience looking at the numbers so i
mean from feedback it's doing great you
know it's okay good so
i don't know
there was some misstarts in getting that
out it was yeah a lot a lot of [ __ ]
like like a lot of hiccups in it and
[ __ ] but but it's out it's all good you
know what i'm saying um we got that um
uh we will be streaming icp is going to
be on twitch very soon that's going to
be at twitch slash icp network you can
check me out right now every tuesday
doing a live podcast called shaggy and
the creep show that's with my partner uh
keegan the creep ass yep and then also
uh it's called the pal cast off so i do
a podcast and then shaggy the creep show
vlogs
which we just going right now [ __ ] we
just did a bunch of [ __ ] in the ozarks
and stuff like that
you were able to
put on put on youtube the footage of me
is like
fireballing in your face yes yes you are
on youtube
it was cool because even vanilla eyes
like sent his footage so i got a couple
different angles
dude how great is vanilla that's my
[ __ ] homie dawg i don't [ __ ] though
that's my i'll i'll fist fight somebody
for him yeah yeah you know what i did i
i fell in love with vanilla
he's a [ __ ] sponsor for boris hot
dogs the [ __ ] out of here wow awesome
that's happening
yeah
i'm a big [ __ ] fan we got to talk to
vanilla ice that would be sick
how did you guys meet like how did you
dude vanilla ice has has performed at at
like every [ __ ] single gathering of
the juggernauts for like 20 years it's
weird it's back in the day when we we uh
do uh jcw the wrestling we would get
like uh
we'd like use our homies as celebrity
impersonators just to be silly and [ __ ]
but then we were like yo let's actually
get vanilla ice you know what i'm saying
have come out [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying and we did we just all kind of
clicked you know what i'm saying so we
just kept kicking it and we just [ __ ]
around and kept doing [ __ ] and
just [ __ ] awesome guy you know what
i'm saying
oh you don't say it
just the the [ __ ] world knowledge on
that man you know what i'm saying he's
just you know people would have vanilla
eyes don't write them off though he's
not at all dude
he brought the fire
at the gathering
come on dog bet you know what's
happening
he threw [ __ ] down dude i mean
yeah
i didn't get to make it to the gathering
but i saw the footage his set looked
awesome yeah
yeah
big shout out to vanilla ice he's the
homie yeah and um
[ __ ] big shout out to you doc shout
out to you man dad i i i really
appreciate you dude i i feel like uh i i
i hit the fred durst jokes too hard man
i [ __ ] oh okay okay good work
you know what i love i love when people
[ __ ] ask me questions because you
know is it so how's the record doing
right you know come on what the [ __ ]
wants to hear that right you know nobody
wants to hear that [ __ ] right i don't
want to hear that [ __ ] yeah you know
what really sucks oh dude i i also wanna
know about it
i'm not gonna tell you what's
it's the only [ __ ] mask i've worn for
weeks on end and uh this is gonna look
like that's like old covid from just
something yeah
and then i'm wearing i'm wearing your
shirt yeah you swagged out man i ain't
got
all the time you guys sent me a big dope
box with these masks i i only wear icp
mask i wear your [ __ ] all the time let's
tell people where to get your [ __ ]
merch it's uh it's that hatchet museum
uh we where where where else is
museum
i don't know i'm trying to [ __ ]
probably what's you guys
i should probably know this
is it what merch now what's the one
yeah but what's the one that we do uh
you know anything we used to do it out
of our warehouse we don't do it like
that no i don't know what the [ __ ] i
don't think i think i didn't google that
we'll find it we'll put it in the
description yeah we'll put it in the
description hey man check the
description for to get
yeah
yeah dude
you're the best dude thank you
and if you want to know where to get the
[ __ ] look at the [ __ ] link in the
bottom however you [ __ ] wear it do
all the algorithm shits you know thumbs
up and comments and all that good [ __ ]
even if the thumbs down it still works
with algorithms right
thumbs down you know these thumbs downs
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i had a good laugh man this was a
blast yeah dude thank you
yeah dude man i do really like shaggy i
i like icp man i'm all about them and uh
you know on this tour i'm hearing so
much about this podcast people are
coming out to me and saying dude i love
your podcast it's almost alarming
you know i've always enjoyed or
appreciated it's meant more to me when
people say ah man i love your youtube
than if they say oh i love jackass
movies
and um
i'm telling you i'm hearing about the
podcast more than anything which which
totally rules
but it also means i've been slouching on
the main channel so yo paul dude let's
[ __ ] get cracking on the main channel
you got it dude
yeah dudes thanks everybody